what's up guys
bang bang plana is just being annoying
today
as usual she's got georgia sweatshirt on
even more annoying but
i love her so i've got no complaints
ever my life is amazing
happy tuesday everyone is here
it's lunch monday time well while she's
trying to get rich russell's just trying
to get our lunch money right
don't forget that block five is not the
sponsor go to blockfy.com
and you can earn up to eight point six
percent apy in an interest bearing
account
or you can sign up for the wait list for
the bitcoin rewards credit card a
regular credit card that will pay you
bitcoin back
no brainer i'm an investor i sit on the
board and i'm a very happy user
you will be too if you get a block by
account go to blockfy.com
why do you always have a toy anthony
come on
okay um dan shulman the ceo of paypal
wrote an op-ed and fortune
i think yes today today saying that
basically
digital currencies will make the economy
more inclusive and his point
is that mainstream adoption of digital
currencies would expand accessibility
particularly for those who are
underrepresented and have lower incomes
the need for this access was evident in
the rollout of pandemic stimulus
payments in the u.s
which were late in reaching and in some
cases failed to reach
millions of unbanked americans many of
whom were people of color or those with
lesser
means those individuals that could
access these much-needed funds were
sadly disproportionately burdened with
cap
check cashing and processing fees and
charges digital wallets and currencies
can help fill this critical
gap and ensure that people can get
direct access to the money
they need instantaneously no brainer of
course
it is going to be more accessible
anytime
you can break down the walled gardens
you can democratize access to something
that's going to be better for the people
who've been kept out of the walled
garden
and that is what we're watching because
wall street they're greedy
they are literally rent sinking rent
seeking middlemen
they're going to be disrupted see ya we
don't need you get out
so it's interesting so the idea here is
that people if they had digital wallets
technically the government could just
drop it in and there would be no fees
and no
well the fees is one part but also just
think of speed if i have to mail you a
check and you have to go cash the check
that seems pretty stupid
there's direct deposit but one that's
expensive and two
uh there's all kinds of issues with it
and so they're
i mean the whole idea of like making it
more efficient so the government can
give you money is pretty stupid
uh it's more about just making
everything more accessible
uh in everyday life it's not about the
government giving you money it's just
literally the the average person in
their daily life their relationship with
uh the currency is going to very very
significantly change
okay crypto investor who bought people's
nft for 69 million dollars says he would
have paid
even more he has no regrets he said he
was prepared to bid even higher
since it will be seen by history as a
starting point of a new age of digital
art
in his first tv interview vignesh also
known as merakovan
uh said i had the opportunity to be part
of this very important shift in how art
has been perceived for centuries
wow i think that uh medecovin
people and many others are very very far
ahead of the curve can i have a question
uh are we just gonna be known with like
these like nicknames from now on if i
could go back
i would have done everything that i did
content-wise on the internet under a
pseudonym
why because you can accrue all the same
value but it not be tied to your real
name and you can walk away at any point
i can't walk away now wait why because
tied to my real name
you can walk away whenever you want you
live in it's a free country
no meaning that like uh medic coven if
he had never said his real name
one day medecovin could have just gone
dark and no one would have ever known
who it was
aka satoshi nakamoto but why does that
matter because maybe he wants to go do
something else
that's fair just saying okay the
pseudonym
economy is going don't you agree that
there's value in tying your identity to
your own name
are you saying but he's tying it to a
pseudonym
[Music]
what's the difference between tying it
to his real name versus tying it to
medicove and
all the value of cruise to wherever the
name is all right next
spotify is moving into live audio the
company says
it will buy betty labs which is a
um clubhouse competitor it they make
they're the makers of live
audio social app locker room that's
focused on sports the terms of the deal
were not announced
shares of spotify were up after the
purchase
hot take what it's not a call pass
competitor is that what you're going
gonna say
no oh go on my hot take is that
uh this is going to be
even more of a movement towards
uh podcasting wait towards podcasting
everyone is talking about the live
social audio being this big trend
uh clubhouse for sure it appears has
value the thing that folks are missing
though
is that it is incredibly time sensitive
or a time intensive
meaning that if i want to listen to a
podcast and the podcast is two hours
long
i can put it on a faster speed i can
like do all these things with
live i have to one be there when it
happens two is i have to do it
uh at the speed of which people talk and
then three is especially when there's no
recordings
i literally am beholden to beholden
and there's no t to the creators and so
what ends up happening is it's the same
reason why like live sports are
uh dissipating everyone wants the
asynchronous relationship i want to
watch it when i want to watch it why do
i have to tune in for the baseball game
right now and so i think over a long
period of time the platforms are going
to significantly
evolve to accommodate recordings and uh
asynchronous uh communication things
like that
uh so it'll be interesting to kind of
watch as that plays out yeah do you
agree
you're saying yep because you're looking
for comments no i'm looking for for
moist i can't find this freaking comment
control f moist moist all right next
topic all right hold on
uh vid okay so volkswagen
is expected to change the name of its
operations in the u.s
to volkswagen of america
this is not a good pun guys why because
it's gonna oh wait why is it not a good
punter why is it changing the name
yeah why is it not a good pun well it's
changing the name because it's
emphasizing its electric vehicle efforts
okay so why is this bad that they're
changing their name
people know that they're volkswagen okay
don't i can't even see that
if you can't even say the regular name
so obviously changing the name might be
more helpful
second of all even more importantly you
don't even add a spell
how do you spell it which one volkswagen
with the k
yeah v-o-l-k-s-w-a-g-e-n
i don't think that's right i don't think
that's right it's correct
click on the link again oh my god it is
correct
you already forgot how i spelled it oh
you're right
spelling bee champion right here i once
i don't spell non-american words i once
aced
i came in like third in the spelling bee
i didn't even know english guys
neither did i at that age all right no
problem next
are we gonna have a guest of honor at
the end we have
extra people here again don't worry all
right
can somebody help me with moist comment
by the way i can't find them okay
um google maps has a wild new feature
that will guide you through
indoor spaces like airports it lets you
navigate
indoors using augmented reality oh my
god i would benefit so much from this
which displays
arrows and markers on your phone screen
to show you exactly where to go this is
great how does it work
so see so technologically
are they using uh no
how are they actually getting the indoor
maps did they go through each mall and
record it does it say
live view for google maps uh searching
something on your google maps tapping
directions
so one of the problems with indoor gps
is that the buildings really can screw
it up
and then also the vertical so are you on
the first floor or the fourth floor
but it tells you go downstairs go this
way this is so cool
i understand but what's likely occurring
is that they've pre-mapped
the airports and then put uh some sort
of
sensor waypoint so that it can tell like
if they use like
um uh the technology like bluetooth
technology or something they can tell
okay you just pass this waypoint that
means you're standing in this part that
can triangulate where you are from a
location standpoint something like that
um what i want to tell everyone though
while polina is looking for moist's
comment
is that it doesn't matter if google maps
literally comes out
with somebody who will walk you to your
location plano will still get lost
pelina has google maps and in new york
city she would get off the subway oh my
god and she literally is looking at the
map
and then she starts walking the wrong
direction but if you want to know why
she does this
it's because polina doesn't believe on
google maps this is literally black
don't believe this
she does not believe in hitting the
direct like the go
losers click on the go button you zoom
in you see where you're supposed to go
and you just go you don't i'm not gonna
stand there she literally
just has where she is on the blue dot
and then she has the location but she
doesn't hit the button that tells you
which way to walk
let me tell you something when you're
standing in new york city and you hit
that
the compass is just going it doesn't
know where you're going well it seemed
to work perfectly fine for me
no it doesn't user error that's the
problem guys user
error i'm scared to say this but i don't
see moisture well
hurry up find it okay did moist mist
wow he could also be getting blocked by
youtube
no see soggy too oh it hasn't been 24
hours i don't care
moist you're in trouble big dog you are
in trouble
all right what's the next topic that's
it that's it oh wait wait wait
wait wow hold on we have are we here
we have all right hold on do we meet our
fate today we have ask
lunch money time hashtag ask hill and we
got some good questions yesterday
matt cunn's cunes i don't know
definitely not spelled [ __ ]
k-u k-u-n-z k-u-n-z
okay what is pomp's favorite taylor
swift song if you don't know the name
off the top of your head you could
always
just sing the chorus for us i would
really like to hear the range he is
mentioning
i like uh 21 that's the song right 28
two 22 oh okay hold on just two
reporters are yelling at me
i said 21 you said 20 somebody over here
said 22 23
27 21 one fourteen do you wanna sing it
i don't know about you but i'm feeling
22. everything will be all right if you
keep me next see here's my problem with
taylor swift we had this conversation at
lunch yes everyone got mad at me
it's contrived it's fake it's wrong i
think this is a good chorus
i like the song no i like the song but
what i'm explaining
is that the entire persona is a
manufactured thing which by the way is
fine
every celebrity every celebrity does it
every celebrity doesn't that's fine
but when somebody calls her out on it
she
then calls cr like foul like oh
they're being mean to me like no you
literally manufactured your whole
persona and now people are calling you
out on it by the way they do that to
everybody they do it to the rock
they don't mess with the rock but they
do it to the rock they do it to
everybody
but the other people don't act like oh
my god they're attacking me they just
keep pushing right there you signed up
for this life can you just be quiet and
sing
now i don't like this one as much that
that's not the part wait which one do
you like
22 oh yeah well how does it go
play it play it real quick i'll sing
along hold on hold on hold on hold on
can you just play
no hit play right here youtube music
youtube music we might get a uh
oh we got an ad now this is oh there's
an ad
youtube stop playing the ads this is
important i got standby
[Music]
same time
yeah this is different from what you
sing together
uh-oh i don't know about you
22 okay
if we get a youtube strike because of
this matt koontz i'm coming for you
that's [ __ ]
okay okay okay one more question one
more question stop
john john loftus paulina is glowing
today
pipe down besides investing disposable
income in bitcoin what three pieces of
advice would you give to someone in
college
oh john good question you're back thanks
i got one
start something on the side just for
yourself whether it's a newsletter or
podcast or something else that you just
do for you
and that's not the advice of have good
surround yourself with good
people that make you a better person
that's number two
well that's why you found me i didn't
find you in college and three
because you were a nerd in college and i
would have been naughty
three is um that's not true
caroline come on it's not only true
that i literally have polina's friend
from high school
that she's literally known the entire
time that will confirm she was a nerd
it's true however i'm also here to drop
some truth and the fact that
your head's getting cut off you look
like you got a bald spot up there
he is a t-swift hater because his true
love is
shania twain oh i do yeah oh wait i'll
tell a story
listen a lot of people don't know this
about me but uh
my mother who uh is obviously an angel
uh literally one summer we drove around
the united states
and there was one cd in the car one
cd-rom
one and that was the shania twain album
and she just kept playing it over and
over and over again until the point
where if you play the song i probably
know every single word still to this day
and so her idea of a great birthday gift
for a like
12 or 13 year old me was to bring me to
a concert
and that concert happened to be shania
twain so the very first live concert i
ever went to at 12 years old was to go
to shania twain
uh i feel like a woman
[Laughter]
that's our best work is that not our
best work that is
okay okay like i have good taste in
music what do you want to sing it no i
don't want to sing that one all right
i gotta go guys lunch money crew it's
great to meet you moist
never meet your hero
what's the next question that that's it
for today
there's no other questions no oh all
right moist we'll talk i'm not i'm not
ready yet to uh say that moist didn't
write anything because it's happened one
time before where we thought he didn't
write anything
and then we found it later so moist this
is me saving you
from the wrath of her i'm just saying
that there is a possibility that you did
not write yet
but there's also a possibility that
polina doesn't know how to use the
internet and therefore she can't find
how is soggy up in here but moist isn't
well pimp on the soggy scale 10 being
soggy and zero being moist
and -10 being wet how mushy is pom
that's soggy's question but
i need to get in the comment section
hold on a second
that's a great question uh paulina you
spot her name wrong
tan is looking golden anthony's is
behind the curve hey all right that's a
stupid comment
uh jeffrey no moist day 28. great show
as always if you dig a post hole
during the wrong time of the moon there
won't be enough dirt to fill the hole
the next day
it's just science that's what you get
when you learn
when you watch this show thank you guys
so much we'll see you tomorrow
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five so go check them
out there's a link in the description
that you can click on
i'm an investor a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block flies my second favorite thing in
the world behind polena they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to eight point six percent
interest on an interest bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to 8.6 interest on a deposit in an
interest bearing account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoying in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends